bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
celui février presque tous les rois et
chefs d'état du monde ont salué une
dernière fois le roi hussein de jordanie
ses funérailles ont c'était l'occasion
de cohabitation inédite
l'avenir de la jordanie du roi abdallah
et celui du processus de paix au proche
orient reste incertain pour la première
fois trois anciens ministres seront
jugés à partir de demain en cour de
justice de la république un mois de
procès d'exception pour tenter de
définir la stabilité politique dans le
drame du sang contaminé
c'est donc un journal particulier que
nous vous proposons ce soir en raison de
l'actualité pendant plus d'une heure
nous serons si vous le voulez bien
ensemble pour évoquer les événements en
france et dans le monde mais surtout
plus longuement pour vous donner les
moyens de comprendre ce qui va se passer
à partir de demain devant la cour de
justice de la république où trois
anciens ministres dont un ancien premier
ministre
comparaîtront accusé d'homicide ce sera
la deuxième partie de cette édition
mais pour commencer nous allons voir ou
revoir pour celles et ceux d'entre vous
qui l'ont suivi sur france 2 de 10h30 à
15h les circonstances des funérailles
mondial du roi hussein à amman la
capitale jordanienne des funérailles
mondiale quand il y avait deux rois et
de chefs d'états d'amis et d'ennemis ou
d'adversaires pour saluer le cercueil du
roi défunt de jordanie pleurer dans les
rues par la foule de son peuple
pleurer à distance par les femmes de la
famille royale interdit de cérémonie
récit françois corner 12 heures à amman
porté par huit colonel de l'armée
jordanienne le cercueil du scène kitsch
de palets balette salam à la périphérie
de la capitale jordanienne la reine nour
qui a partagé pendant vingt ans la vie
du scène après trois autres épouses
la compagne du dernier combat sur la vie
de la mort devra comme les autres femmes
de la maison des hachémites faire ses
adieux au souverain jordanien ici sur
les marches du palais la tradition
musulmane interdit aux femmes d'assister
aux obsèques
la dépouille du monarque enveloppé dans
le drapeau noir vert rouge et blanc
jordanien va parcourir une vingtaine de
kilomètres jusqu'au palais ragga dan le
palais royal
la foule au départ peu nombreuses à
s'épaissir au fur et à mesure de la
progression du convoi mortuaire ce
peuple que l'on croyait quelque peu
marginalisés par ses obsèques au profit
d'une cérémonie plus officiel s'appuyant
sur la présence des grands de ce monde a
débordé le service d'ordre
voulant lui aussi être en communion avec
le départ de son souverain qu'il
pleurait déjà depuis trois jours
brillant pour un miracle qui ne s'est
pas produit première étape du convoi
mortuaire le palais royal où les
personnalités vont se recueillir devant
le cercueil du souverain hachémite avant
les prières à la mosquée le corps du roi
est déposée au milieu de la salle du
trône
orienté vers la ville sainte de la
mecque
moment historique le président syrien
hafez el-assad
l'ancien ennemi du roi hussein venus
s'incliner sur la dépouille de celui
qu'il avait cherché à déstabiliser car
trop proche des israéliens
le président clinton accompagnée des
trois anciens présidents américains
george bush jimmy carter et gerald ford
yasser arafat le président palestinien
qui avait rencontré pour la dernière
fois une scène à wye plantation
durant les négociations de paix avec les
israéliens
les israéliens construits construit par
le président weissman et le premier
ministre benyamin nétanyahou qui
s'incline devant la dépouille de celui
que l'on surnommait au proche orient
l'artisan de paix recueillement du
président jacques chirac accompagné de
bernard kouchner secrétaire d'état à la
santé qui était en visite officielle au
proche-orient au moment du décès du roi
hussein boris eltsine avait tenu à faire
le voyage
contre l'avis de ses médecins le
président russe qui se remet d'un ulcère
aiguille à l'estomac a été pris d'un
léger malaise durant cette cérémonie et
a dû repartir vers moscou sans pouvoir
s'incliner devant la dépouille du roi
hussein
après ce dernier hommage d'une
quarantaine de chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement et de têtes couronnées
la dépouille du roi a été transporté
vers la mosquée amné abd el moutaleb
elle pour la prière des morts au son de
la cornemuse dans un rituel très
britannique hussein se dirige vers sa
dernière demeure
il va devenir alors un simple croyais en
retournant à la terre on le retire de
son cercueil pour l'enveloppé dans un
simple linceul blanc
le souverain hachémite qui dirigeait le
pays depuis l'âge de 17 ans reposera
couché sur le côté droit face à la
mecque dans le cimetière familial
jouxtant le palais royal
sur la colline jebel al hussein aux
côtés de son père talal et de son grand
père abdallah sous son châle blanc à
l'écart la reine nour
elle s'est enfermée dans son chagrin la
population jordanienne a suivi tantôt
avec une émotion contenue parfois de
façon plus hystérique ses obsèques d'un
roi qui a marqué la jeune histoire de
son pays au passage du convoi est plus
celui ci s'approcher du palais royal
ce sont des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui manifestaient
voyez le reportage d'isabelle steiss
patrick voix et monsieur armes au début
c'est dans le calme et le silence qu'ils
se sont rassemblés depuis tôt ce matin
ils attendent dans un froid glacial
ils se sont postés un peu partout les
forces de l'ordre les tiennent à
distance pour l'instant nous sommes près
du palais rade gagnent là où tout à
l'heure sera enterré leurs droits notre
roi est parti moi je suis palestinienne
il était si généreux on l'aimé tant j'ai
perdu mon père mon frère l'être le plus
cher de ma vie je sens que je suis perdu
je n'arrive pas y croire
ils les attendent depuis maintenant deux
heures leur bout leur est trop forte
la foule s'agite l'armée s'inquiètent
lorsque le cortège funèbre apparaît au
loin
la foule se déchaîne et les centaines de
soldats présents ici sont totalement
dépassées
ils ont fusé en tête s'approcher de la
dépouille royale comme s'il voulait une
dernière fois touché le roi
il va courir ainsi jusqu'à ce que les
forces de l'ordre leur barrent le chemin
le cortège funèbre est déjà loin la
foule elle est en état de choc
c'est un moment très dur on a perdu
quelqu'un de trop important c'était le
pilier de notre pays de notre maison
j'ai perdu mon père ils et elles adorent
et du peuple jordanien dans le monde
entier il n'y a personne comme lui il
n'ya pas de peuple qui autant aimé son
roi il est 13h30
la dépouille royale arrive aux portes du
palais rag dan
c'est là que le peuple jordanien va
quitter son roi à la périphérie de la
capitale amman dans le camp de réfugiés
palestiniens de baca c'était aussi jour
de deuil mais les familles
palestiniennes rencontrés par nos
envoyés spéciaux maryse burgot et
philippe jasselin exprimaient des
sentiments mêlés
reportage les versets du coran les
drapeaux noirs sur les portraits du roi
des saints et les magasins fermés
les habitants de bach un en banlieue
dahmane sont eux aussi en deuil ils
vivent dans le plus grand camp de
réfugiés du moyen-orient ils sont
d'origine palestinienne comme 70% de la
population jordanienne
il n'en reste pas moins attaché à leroy
et s'ils n'ont pas fait le voyage vers
la capitale pour voir passer le cortège
funèbre
ils ont majoritairement suivi les
retransmissions en direct à la
télévision
ce père de famille s'est installée dans
le camp en 1976 les palestiniens
fuyaient alors leur cisjordanie perdu
après la guerre des six jours
depuis abou haslach a eu des enfants et
même des petits enfants il fait
confiance au nouveau roi pour tenter de
sauver le processus de paix au
moyen-orient comme le fit son père si
dieu le veut
abdallah va nous aider à réaliser le
rêve d'un état palestinien
ici c'est un peu notre deuxième patrie
et il ne va pas nous oublier de roy
était tolérant et même généreux envers
nous
mais les palestiniens de barca se
souviennent aussi de septembre noir
c'était en 70 le roi hussein réprimait
alors dans le sens leur tentative de
prendre le pouvoir
le cheikh rate un responsable du camp
n'a pas oublié cette violence mais en ce
jour de deuil
il ne veux pas ressasser le passé le roi
hussein savez pardonner même à ses
adversaires
alors nous aussi les palestiniennes de
baca veulent-elles aussi penser à
l'avenir et il s'annonce difficile
65% de la population du camp a
aujourd'hui moins de 25 ans si le taux
de chômage est pire que dans le reste de
la jordanie surtout chez les jeunes
dans le camp de base qu'un un
palestinien sur cinq vit aujourd'hui en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
après la disparition de son père le roi
a maintenant un défi à relever améliorée
au plus vite la situation économique
dans son pays et dans les camps
palestiniens
sinon le mécontentement populaire
discret en ce jour de deuil pourrait
aboutir à de nouvelles révoltes comme ce
fut le cas il ya tout juste un an dans
le sud du pays
les palestiniens qui représente donc
plus de la moitié de la population
jordanienne estimées actuellement
environ 5,4 millions de personnes le
pays est essentiellement urbain la
capitale amman compte 2 millions
d'habitants elle s'est énormément
transformée elle symbolise bien
l'évolution d'un royaume hachémite dont
les frontières furent tracées d'un coup
de crayon selon chuck chine et qui fut
le théâtre de multiples combats
évocation avec charles enderlin
juin 1916 fousseyni ben ali chérif de la
mecque et roi du et jazz en arabie
proclame la grande révolte arabe contre
l' empire ottoman
il rêve de devenir calife d'établir un
royaume arabe qui ré jusqu'en syrie ses
fils fayçal et abdallah mène le combat
aux côtés de l'armée britannique et le 2
octobre 1918 fayçal entrant vainqueur à
damas mais les grandes puissances ont
d'autres projets les français occupent
la syrie en expulse fayçal prix de
consolation les britanniques lui offre
un royaume sur mesure ce sera l'irak
avec bagdad pour capitale le frère kader
dallas veut sa part du gâteau et en mars
1921 avec six cavaliers il débarque en
plein désert dans un petit village
appelé amman et décide d'y créer son
émirat dont un dimanche après-midi
winston churchill trace les frontières
la future jordanie vient de naître est
là pour voisine
à l'ouest la palestine où le mouvement
sioniste créé le foyer national juif
promis par la grande bretagne qui
gouverne ce territoire pour les
hachémites les choses vont mal un clan
rival les excuses de la mecque en 1924
et l'arabie devient saoudienne le
royaume hachémite d'irak ne sera
renversée qu'en 1958 à amman avec l'aide
et les conseils des anglais abdallah sur
mantes crise sur crise surtout la guerre
de 1948 qui voit la naissance d'israël
son arme et occupe jérusalem-est et la
cisjordanie qu ils annexent ce qui avec
l'arrivée de centaines de milliers de
réfugiés palestiniens
triple la population du royaume une
population qui rejette sa politique de
rapprochement avec le jeune état juif
il tente de négocier un traité de paix
mais il est assassiné en 1951 par un
palestinien
un problème que son petit-fils coup
scène qui lui succède deux ans plus tard
affrontera tout au long de son règne
l'equilibre souvent difficiles entre les
bédouins soutien traditionnel du roi et
les palestiniens majoritaire dans le
royaume la perte de la cisjordanie et de
jérusalem-est lors de la guerre de juin
1967 n'améliorera pas les choses crues
scène avec commis l'erreur de s'allier à
la syrie à l'egypte face à israël
l'émergence du mouvement national
palestinien dirigé par yasser arafat
menacent la stabilité du royaume en
septembre 1970 le soulèvement
palestinien soutenu par la syrie est
écrasé par les bédouins de rousset il y
a des milliers de morts dans les camps
de réfugiés au fil des ans les
adversaires se réconcilieront mérou
scène pour ne pas éveiller l'opposition
de ses sujets palestiniens gardera
secret de ses relations avec israël des
liens qui dès 1974 ont l'aspect d'une
alliance stratégique
toute chose qui irrite des ennemis
d'israël dans la région notamment
rappelle el assad le président syrien
autre élément déstabilisateur la crise
économique
endémique que connaît le royaume coup
scène espère la résoudre par une paix
régionale
mais toujours prudent il attend la
signature de l'accord d'oslo entre
israël et l'olp et pour conclure son
traité de paix avec l'état juif
en octobre 1994 mais cette paix
n'apporte pas les dividendes promis les
investisseurs étrangers ne se précipite
pas à amman
l'agitation sociale et menaçante des
émeutes éclatent en 1996 et en 1997 le
blocage des négociations
israélo-palestiniennes durcit encore
l'atmosphère dans la région où la paix
globale dont rêvait hussein reste une
utopie c'est donc en jordanie que de
nombreux souverains et chefs d'état du
monde entier se sont côtoyés ce matin
exceptionnellement au nom du respect
qu'il portait au roi hussein de bill
clinton à boris eltsine venu malgré
l'avis de ses médecins du syrien hafez
el-assad un israélien netanyahou de
l'algérien zeroual au prince d'arabie
saoudite du roi d'espagne à tony blair
tous manifestaient ainsi une forme de
reconnaissance pour l'action de paix
menées par le défunt selon les propos de
monsieur chirac
d'abord c'est le départ de sage et d'un
homme de paix d'une région qui a bien
besoin
ensuite j'ai été très frappé par là
l'excellente manière dont les
institutions fonctionnent et ce qui est
très important pour l'avenir
le nouveau roi a été désigné il est
attendu ici par tous
avec sans aucun doute beaucoup
respectueuse amitié affection et donc
cela augure bien de l'avenir
et enfin j'ai l'occasion de rencontrer
je ne connaissais déjà et plusieurs fois
l'agent de le voir et je veux dire que
cet art one qui sans aucun doute on peut
mettre sa confiance en tous les cas la
france lui apportera son soutien et lui
donnant sa conférence en israël à la une
d'un grand quotidien populaire il y
avait ce titre ce matin à dieu à l'ami
écrit en arabe et en hébreu tous les
responsables du gouvernement et de
l'opposition se sont associés pour un
hommage au souverain décédé celui ci
était présenté comme l'homme du traité
de paix avec israël en 94 sur les lieux
mêmes où fut assassiné le premier
ministre israélien monsieur de sac
un rabin beaucoup d'israéliens sont
venus se recueillir ce matin réunissant
ainsi dans un même hommage hussein de
jordanie et monsieur rabhi s'agissant
des réactions en cisjordanie dans les
territoires sous l'autorité
palestinienne voyez le reportage de
charles enderlin et allan gregg au
pendant toute la durée des obsèques les
drapeaux étaient en berne sur les
édifices publics en israël devant
l'entrée de l'ambassade de jordanie à
tel aviv quelques israéliens étaient
venus allumer une bougie du souvenir
également place rabin à l'endroit où le
premier ministre israélien a été
assassiné le 5 novembre 1995
dans le grand centre commercial de
jérusalem-ouest des israéliens
s'arrêtaient devant le téléviseur km/h à
la marche alors dans leurs démarches et
dans les territoires palestiniens la
population observe le deuil de trois
jours décrétée par l'autorité autonome
de yasser arafat et là aussi on a suivi
les obsèques de roues scène diffusée en
direct par toutes les chaînes de la
région
chez les islamistes les sentiments sont
mitigés le cheikh ahmad yassine le
fondateur du ramasse regrette la
disparition du roi hussein qui avait
obligé israël à le libérer
il craint à présent une déstabilisation
de la région
en l'absence du souverain hachémite
c'est également l'avis dallas savent pas
où il ya un dirigeant du jihad islamique
je crois que le plan américain va être
très lourd ou le peuple palestinien et
ce plan va fait entrer la région du
moyen orient dans un nouveau phase de
conflit et de violence craintes pour
l'avenir tristesse c'est le ton pour des
raisons différentes en israël et dans
les territoires palestiniens
charles enderlin vous venez de dire
craintes pour la pour l'avenir alors
après ce bel hommage unanime d'une
journée ce qu'il y ait effectivement des
craintes à avoir
les israéliens aimerait bien savoir si
le roi abdallah continuera sur la voie
d'une paix chaleureuse avec israël comme
la goulette son frère il attendra
certainement les élections en israël
deuxième tour le 2 juin pour prendre une
décision
proposition palestinienne risque en
effet de ne pas apprécier une poursuite
du blocage du processus de paix cela dit
on voudrait savoir aussi en israël
si le roi par exemple comme son père
acceptera de participer à l'alliance
militaire israélo-turques une alliance
puissante qui est née
proche orient il ya moins de deux ans
que qui inquiète certains pays arabes
peut-on penser qu'il ya une sorte de
nouvelle physionomie du proche-orient
une redistribution des cartes avec
l'arrivée du roi abdallah lors abdallah
symbolise certainement l'arrivée d'un
nouveau proche orient alors que la
population dans la région que les une
croissance démographique sans précédent
aussi bien en jordanie nous l'avons
entendu tout à l'heure mais aussi dans
les territoires palestiniens à gaza par
exemple 55 % de la population a moins de
15 ans s'il y avait en france la même
densité de population qu'à gaza
il y aurait 2 milliards de français et
tout cela alors que les ressources en
eau par exemple s'épuisent et que la
région visiblement s'oriente vers des
crises économique et sociale très grave
au moment où les grands leaders
nationalistes pragmatique quitte la
scène politique
merci charles en a donc observé avec
attention le comportement des pays
voisins de la jordanie et de la
cisjordanie dans le monde arabe le mage
est quasi générale mais la presse
iranienne qualifié ce matin le roi
hussein de traîtres à la cause
palestinienne et rappelle que
l'ayatollah khomeiny avait qualifié le
roi hussein de personnes répugnante
parce qu'il était très proche du shah
d'iran et puis au liban gouvernement
publié un communiqué disant laconique
tandis que la presse libanaise était
très critique à l'égard du roi hussein
en revanche les taliban de kaboul les
responsables des pays du golfe et on l'a
vu le président syrien faisait la saab
ont apporté leur soutien au nouveau roi
abdallah il est donc intéressant ce soir
sur la carte de cette région du monde
entre syrie israël et irak de saddam
hussein d'apprécier les perspectives
politiques commentaires bernard lebrun
le proche orient
à l'heure de succession difficile yasser
arafat 70 ans
hafez al-assad 69 ans le roi fahd
d'arabie 79 ans trois dinosaures
politiques trois dirigeants arabes sans
réel successeur est malade démarche peu
assurée lèvres tremblantes
le leader palestinien semble frapper des
syndromes de la maladie de parkinson et
pourtant personne n'oserait contester à
yasser arafat qui lui revient de droit
de proclamer aux termes des accords
d'oslo cette année
la naissance de l'état palestinien
l'homme qui depuis 30 ans conduit
incarne tel emblème la lutte nationale
palestinienne ne se préoccupe pas de sa
succession après lui viendront les
luttes de clans et l'inconnu pas un pays
d'occident
pas plus qu israël le connaissent
aujourd'hui le nom de leurs futurs
interlocuteurs palestiniens 28 ans de
pouvoir sans partage
ça fatigue le syrien hafez el-assad sera
pourtant réélu président demain par son
parlement
candidat unique à un nouveau mandat de
sept ans il n'a plus passé la main son
fils aîné bassel successeur désigné
s'est tué dans un accident de voiture
voilà cinq ans le frère cadet bachar
pourraient être investis dauphin mais
voilà il n'a que 34 ans et la
constitution syrienne fixe l'âge du
président à 40 ans mouvement militaire
arrivé au pouvoir par un coup d'état
hafez al assad se comporte tel un
monarque tentant d'imposer sa famille
pour dynasty autocrate fatigué le
président syrien usera pour sa
succession tout comme pour son règne
en arabie saoudite pouvoir se conjugue
avec famille celle du roi fahd
patriarche de 83 ans des saoud
bien que malade depuis quatre années ils
refusent d'appliquer dans ce pays où 75%
de la population a moins de 30 ans le
roi a désigné pour héritier son frère de
76 ans le prince abdallah un manne
pétrolière des années de prospérité
n'est plus en raison de l'effondrement
des cours mais la stabilité intérieure
du pays dépend surtout d'un état
providence forcément riche et puissant
au moment où sortent des universités
laisse enfants de la croissance le
chômage apparaît avec son cortège de
mécontents venant grossir les rangs des
islamistes qui constituent les rares
mouvements d'opposition à la famille
royale
l'autre partie de la jeunesse rompu aux
affaires avec l'occident qui réclame une
véritable démocratisation du régime
saoudien
l'ère des dinosaures politiques sur
lesquels l'occident a dû compter bon gré
mal gré est sur son déclin
demain à l'image de ce prince il est
inconnu devenu roi abdallah de jordanie
c'est une nouvelle génération à qui sera
confiée le proche orient
et au soir de cette journée solennelle
de deuil tout le monde y compris la
banque mondiale promet maintenant de
soutenir le nouveau roi abdallah
philippe rochot écouter ce qui a rassuré
les chefs d'état du monde entier
présents ici à amman c'est de voir que
finalement le roi abdallah était
solidement installée qu'il possédait
bien ses dossiers et qu'il était prêt à
tenir les rênes du pouvoir et les
quelque cinquante délégations présentes
ici qui ont défilé devant la dépouille
du roi hussein montre en tout cas que la
jordanie ne sera pas isolé et il en aura
besoin parce que la jordanie reste quand
même un état fragile
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est de voir que
finalement de nouvelles relations vont
s'établir entre les états par exemple on
a vu le syrien hafez el-assad être le
premier à présenter ses condoléances au
roi abdallah alors que la syrie et la
jordanie ont été pendant des années
en froid dans leurs relations
diplomatiques on a vu aussi yasser
arafat se précipiter vers le roi
abdallah parce qu'il a besoin de son
soutien
donc ce sera très important pour les
prochaines échéances diplomatiques c'est
à dire bien sûr toujours les élections
israéliennes la proclamation de l'état
palestinien
la poursuite des négociations le
problème avec l'irak également puisque
la jordanie était très lié à l'irak
tout au moins jusqu'à ces derniers temps
aujourd'hui on a vu surprise des chefs
d'état des monarchies arabes défilé ici
avec des promesses dans leur sac
promettant notamment de réapprovisionner
la jordanie en pétrole puisque vous
savez que le koweït et l'arabie avait
coupé l'approvisionnement en pétrole au
lendemain de la guerre du golfe et que
la jordanie étaient obligés de
s'approvisionner auprès de l'irak
donc tout cela fait que finalement le
roi abdallah prend un bon départ on peut
le dire pour affronter tous les
problèmes internationaux qui vont se
poser à lui durant les semaines et les
mois à venir
voilà pour l'actualité ses conséquences
l'actualité de la mort du roi hussein et
ses obsèques célébrées aujourd'hui à man
en allemagne les sociaux démocrates et
écologistes au pouvoir ont connu une
sévère défaite hier aux élections
régionales de hesse cette défaite leur
coûte la majorité absolue au bundesrat
la chambre haute du parlement fédéral
c'est un handicap pour le gouvernement
de monsieur choix d'air commentaires
olivier lerner et arnaud cance l'air
y a de la joie dans le camp des
chrétiens-démocrates une spectaculaire
reconquête en s la région de francfort
la plus riche du pays bascule à droite
majorité absolue pour l'accès des eaux
des routes pour les verts douche froide
pour le spd et ses militants de gauche
qui n'en reviennent pas roland corps
sera peut être le prochain président du
bundesrat la chambre haute du parlement
pourra se dresser contre les projets de
loi gouvernementaux corp a fait campagne
contre la réforme du code de nationalité
qui déchaîne les passions
la retraite qui me revient c'est vous
les étrangers qui allaient en profiter
mais non mais non les étrangers n'ont
rien à voir avec ça c'est l'état c'est
l'état pas les étrangers s'ils ne suis
pas votre retraite
moi j'y suis pour rien
vidé les caisses de l'état allemand
prenez tout ce qu'on a dans les caisses
de sécurité sociale et pour ne rien
arranger guérin schröder a commis des
erreurs de débutants ces dernières
semaines la sortie du nucléaire
reporter la réforme des impôts mal
accepté la double nationalité accordé
aux étrangers rejetée par une majorité
d'allemands
conséquence le projet pourrait être revu
et corrigé
une première gifle pour schröder la
presse allemande met bien l'accent sur
le sévère camouflet infligé au
chancelier qui du même coup va permettre
à l'opposition de se faire entendre à
nouveau c'est bien la fin de l'état de
grâce pour le numéro un allemand qui
vient juste de passer le cap des cent
jours à la chancellerie en afrique de
l'est les combats continuent entre
l'ethiopie et l'erythrée l'onu à
l'organisation de l'unité africaine a
appelé à la cessation immédiate des
combats les affrontements pour origine
des zones contestées par l'erythrée dans
le nord ouest de son voisin éthiopien en
france à paris des agriculteurs ont
saccagé les bureaux du ministère de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
l'environnement ainsi que des locaux de
l'ena une quinzaine d'agriculteurs sont
toujours gardés à vue ce soir le
président de la fnsea a désapprouvé
cette action de protestation contre la
réforme de la politique agricole commune
le ministre et culture monsieur glavany
a condamné ces saccages qualifié de
scandaleux par madame voynet
commentaires patrick chan diot
le bureau de dominique voynet ou du
moins ce qu'il en reste quelques minutes
après la descente musclée d'une
soixantaine d'agriculteurs de la boue et
des petits pois sur les moquettes et les
tables de la farine sur les visages des
collaborateurs au ministère on apprécie
pas tous les bureaux sur leur passage
ont été visités et celui-ci de bureaux
des ministres étant situés dans un en
particulier a été le plus visité et le
plus dévasté la remarque personnelle et
écuyers des choses ont été prises
d'ailleurs dedans comportement très
surprenant les forces de l'ordre sont
arrivées trop tard la sécurité du
ministère seulement assurée par quelques
agents a vite été débordés
dominique voynet était en déplacement en
province elle a jugé scandaleux le
comportement des agriculteurs je ne sais
qui manipule qui agite telle ou telle
catégorie du monde paysan
mais ça me paraît pas et dans le bon
sens si on veut pouvoir élaborer
ensemble des solutions qui satisfassent
aux contraintes économiques et aux
difficultés du monde agricole
après le ministère les manifestants ont
brièvement occupé les locaux de l'ena
avant d'être expulsés et interpellés par
la police
une nouvelle fois ils souhaitaient
protester contre la baisse des prix des
produits agricoles prévu par bruxelles
dans le cadre de la réforme de la pac
pourtant aucune décision n'est prise et
les actions spectaculaires de la base ce
matin embarrasse la direction du
principal syndical agricole
ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya eu un
dérapage et une action mal préparée et
mal contrôlée par certains responsables
qui font condamner l'ensemble et
j'espère bien que cette action ne se
renouvellera pas pendant ces actions
syndicales que nous menons at one 15 des
200 personnes interpellées sont toujours
en garde à vue
le premier ministre lionel jospin a
promis des poursuites judiciaires
a grenoble ce matin les chauffeurs de
transports en commun se sont mis en
grève après un incendie volontaire hier
soir d'un bus d'un groupe de jeunes
montés à l'arrière du véhicule aurait
jeté un engin incendiaire le chauffeur a
perdu contrôle de l'autobus il n'y a pas
de blessé mais les machinistes des
transports en commun de grenoble on
réclame de meilleures conditions de
sécurité dans le dossier de la sphère
des disparus de mourmelon datant d'avril
87 et doute 88,3 analyses génétiques ont
été apportées au juge ses analyses
indiquent de très fortes probabilités de
la présence de trois des huit victimes
présumées dans le véhicule de l'ex
adjudant pierre chanal le contrôle
judiciaire de pierre chanal pourraient
être renforcées il est sorti de prison
en juin 95 explications stéphane
breitner didier guyot et gilles jacquier
pour la première fois depuis sa
libération sous contrôle judiciaire en
95 des images de pierre chanal c'est un
homme presque masquer que notre caméra a
pu surprendre lors de l'une de ses rares
sorties un homme toujours sous la menace
de la justice
il aura fallu trois ans pour analyser
400 cheveux et poils retrouver dans son
convient et les expertises génétiques
ont parlé l'adn prélevé sur ses
échantillons correspondrait à celui de
trois disparus avec une probabilité
proche de 100% le conclusions des
rapports d expertise sont importantes
puisque elle semble faire porter sur le
mise en examen
des charges tout à fait sérieuse dans ce
rapport trois noms très fort au kif un
jeune irlandais dont on a retrouvé le
corps en 87
patrice denis disparu en 85 enfin
patrick gâche introuvable depuis 12 ans
les parties civiles veulent maintenant
que le juge avance vite ça veut dire à
mon sens prendre les mesures pour que
monsieur chanel retourne en détention ça
veut dire faire en sorte qu'il soit jugé
très rapidement par la cour d'assises
département de la main la défense
insiste sur la fragilité de ces analyses
on est dans une matière très nouvelle
très récente des expertises adn c'est
quelque chose qui encore une fois date
de peu d'années est donc dans ces
matières la science tâtonne on sait très
bien que lorsqu elle tâtonne elle peut
se tromper
donc je crois qu'il faut être très très
prudent par rapport à ses résultats
le juge d'instruction a demandé un
renforcement de son contrôle judiciaire
il devrait l'entendre avant la fin du
mois quant à son arrestation
elle ne serait possible qu'en cas de
procès puisqu'il a déjà été jugé en 90
pour une affaire conjointe
finalement ces résultats prouverait que
trois disparus sont montés dans le combi
de pierre chanal mais il en reste
toujours 4 dont on ne sait rien face à
la concurrence de nouveaux opérateurs
france télécom annonce une nouvelle
grille tarifaire destiné à séduire les
particuliers et arrive sûrement baisse
le samedi matin pour certaines
communications contrepartie de ces
cadeaux l'abonnement téléphonique va
quand même augmenté de 10 francs dès le
mois de mars prochain
explications avec eric lemasson il en va
des factures de téléphone comme des
régimes amaigrissants le poids à
l'arrivée tombe rarement au niveau des
allégements promis demain de nouvelles
baisses de tarifs seront annoncées par
france télécom en voici les grandes
lignes
extension du demi-tarif à toute la
journée du samedi et non plus à l'après
midi seulement baisse de 15% environ du
prix des appels interurbains et
internationaux autre nouveauté un tarif
spécial pour les allocataires des minima
sociaux sous forme d'un forfait mensuel
moins cher c'est pour s'aligner sur la
concurrence que les appels longue
distance sont soldées sur tout le week
end
le set de cegetel a déjà décroché six
cent cinquante mille abonnement france
telecom sa ligne pour ne pas perdre trop
de clients mais son tarif allégé d'un
côté s'alourdit de l'autre le service du
12 les renseignements passe à 4 francs
50 et surtout l'abonnement augmenterait
de 10 francs par mois une hausse de près
de 15% qui est loin d'être négligeable
l'abonnement et les communications
locales représentent la ligne de la plus
lourde
dans la majorité des factures le décès
de l'économiste américain va civil et
ont tué fils fut prix nobel d'économie
en 73 on considère comme à l'origine la
comptabilité nationale très utilisé par
les économistes et les planificateurs et
puis sport cyclisme l'équipe espagnole
on sait dont le leader et le français
laurent jalabert déclare forfait pour
paris nice cette équipe voudrait éviter
la france et sa réglementation
concernant les affaires de dopage
nous allons maintenant longuement vous
proposer quelques éléments de
compréhension du procès dit du sang
contaminé qui s'ouvre demain devant la
cour de justice de la république nous
avons combas peine judiciaire les
accusés les victimes et quelques unes
des interrogations posées par ce procès
intenté à trois anciens ministres
laurent fabius georgina dufoix edmond
hervé pour la période où ils furent
respectivement premier ministre ministre
des affaires sociales et secrétaire
d'état à la santé
les faits qui leur sont reprochés datent
de 1984 à 1985 mais plus largement
voici la chronologie du dossier dit du
sang contaminé 5 année qui s'ouvre avec
une publication américaine en 1981
annonçant une maladie inconnue en cas de
jean daniel flaysakier olivier caroff et
benoît thevenet tout commence ici au cdc
le centre de contrôle des maladies
d'atlanta à la pharmacie on s'étonne de
commandes anormalement élevé de penthaz
midi ce médicament très une pneumonie
rare qui frappe habituellement les
drogués et les greffés cette fois c'est
différent
les malades ont des points communs et
inhabituelle
le 4 juin 1981 le bulletin du cdc publie
les premiers cas de ce qu'on appellera
que plus tard le sida d'octobre 80
années 80 cinq jeunes hommes tous
homosexuels ont été traité pour une
pneumonie à pneumocystis deux d'entre
eux sont morts
en 82 des cas de sida apparaissent chez
des hémophiles amérique en 83 toujours
aux états unis un enfant de 20 mois
ayant reçu de multiples transfusions
murs du sida parmi les dix-huit
d'honneur on retrouve une personne
atteinte de la maladie au plan
scientifique 83 est une étape importante
une équipe française publie le 20 mai
dans le journal science
la découverte d'un nouveau virus le
virus est baptisé elle avait luc
montagnier pense qu'il est la course du
sida mais peu de scientifiques le coin
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de d'accueil
favorable dans la communauté
scientifique qui travaille dans ce
domaine qui s'était spécialiste des
rétrovirus et ceci a duré jusqu au mois
de
février mars 1984 dans beaucoup de moi
qui on peut dire est respectivement été
un petit peu perdu mais l'idée que le
sida est causé par un agent infectieux
transmissibles par le sang fait son
chemin en particulier chez les trente
six heures à l'époque il y à 160 centres
de transfusion en france tous
indépendants les uns des autres
sept d'entre eux fabriquent des produits
dérivés du plasma sanguin notamment pour
les hémophiles
le cnds centre national de transfusion
sanguine est l'un d'eux il n'a malgré
son nom aucune autorité sur les autres
centres
sa seule mission nationale le monopole
de l'importation des produits sanguins
en juin la commission consultative de la
transfusion s'inquiètent en s'apercevant
que dans un groupe de six jeunes
hémophiles sans doute contaminer la
moitié des garçons a reçu des produits
français
dans ce bureau
un homme décide alors d'agir c'est le
directeur général de la santé un titre
qui fait de jacques roux le plus haut
responsable administratif dans le
domaine sanitaire au dessus de lui
il n'y a que les politiques un
secrétaire d'état et une - hervé est
encore plus haut un ministre georgina
dufoix le 20 juin jacques roux envoie
une circulaire au centre de transfusion
ils demandent une sélection des donneurs
en écartant notamment les utilisateurs
de drogues injectables par voie veineuse
les homosexuels ou bisexuels à
partenaires multiples voulait que le
capitaine estime des deux ministres soit
dans le coup parce que parce qu'ils ne
l'étaient pas beaucoup jusqu'à ce moment
là mais est-ce que à ce moment est-ce
que ans en juin 83
vous aviez la volonté et les moyens
d'imposer cette sélection des donneurs
la volonté willémois yano à l'époque une
partie du sang français provient des
prisons là où justement toxicomanie et
homosexualité sont monnaie courante mais
six mois après la circulaire une autre
administration la pénitentiaire autorise
l'augmentation dû rythme des collectes
dans les grands établissements
ce sens va infecter de nombreuses poches
de transfusions et quelques cuves de
produits pourris mot cible
20 ans 84 jean pierre allain du cnts
présente une étude portant sur 405
hémophiles 47% d'entre eux sont
contaminés 30 septembre le docteur
garetta remplace le professeur souliers
à la direction du cnts 22 novembre le
docteur jean baptiste brunet annonce que
chauffer le plasma pendant 24 heures à
68 degrés permet d'inactiver le virus du
sida
mais la preuve définitive de
l'efficacité du chauffage n'est pas
encore fait
la sélection des donneurs elle est en
panne en janvier 85 jacques roux réécrit
au centre de transfusion il rappelle sa
circulaire de 83 et il lance un
avertissement la responsabilité des
établissements qui n'appliqueraient pas
à ces mesures pourraient être mis en
cause
pourtant dans certaines prisons les
collectes continue en 1985 j'étais
médecin à l'hôpital de des prisons de
fresnes et j'ai alerté les autorités
concernant les dons du sang les
collectes de sang en milieu carcéral
ces collectes ont été stoppées il a
fallu quelques mois pour les stopper
il est vrai qu'elles ont continué dans
certains établissements et des centres
de transfusion ont continué à prélever
parallèlement une guerre industrielle
franco américaine couvre le 27 avril 84
la secrétaire d'état américaine à la
santé annonce que l'équipe du professeur
diallo vient de découvrir le virus du
sida
le 4 mai à nant après montagne et gallo
publie ses travaux dans saillantes sans
virus s'appelle htlv 3 galop à un accord
avec la firme abbott de chicago pour la
mise au point de tests de dépistage mais
en france on trouve que le virus de
gallons ressemble comme deux gouttes
d'eau à celui découvert par lés
pasteurien est justement la société
diagnostics pasteur développe elle aussi
un test à partir de la découverte
française en france l'homme chargé
d'autoriser ces tests s'appelle robert
né terre il dirige le laboratoire
national de la santé
le 8 janvier 85 il reçoit un premier
dossier celui du test à bord
un mois et demi plus tard ces
diagnostics pasteur qui annonce sont
les américains ont donc une longueur
d'avancé le problème devient politique
et va franchir les portes des ministères
28 mars
le docteur n'est terre écrit au cabinet
d'edmond hervé ils proposent une
procédure d'homologation plus longue
dans l'intérêt de la firme française
pasteur 20 avril le même cabinet reçoit
une note du docteur brunet le
spécialiste du sida la dgs il note que
l'administration a retardé jusqu'ici de
deux mois l'enregistrement de ce réactif
et à donner à pasteur production le
temps de rattraper son retard
son supérieur jacques roux je suis la
sphère de près le 30 avril il écrit à
propos d'abbott
il ne faudrait pas qu'il sorte en tant
que pasteur n'a pas pris son essor
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que se
tient début mai une réunion
interministérielle sur le dépistage
elle est présidée par françois gros
conseiller scientifique de laurent
fabius son compte rendu est clair il est
à craindre que si aucune disposition de
prises pour protéger le test français
celui ci soit complètement exclues du
marché on après essayé de privilégier le
test français
on a essayé de faire en sorte à l'époque
tels que les informations m'ont été
donnés par les autres représentants des
ministères de faire en sorte que le test
français dans les centres de transfusion
qui devaient à terme en être dotées ne
soit pas encore quelque sorte oublié par
rapport aux tests américains juin 85 le
cnts distribuer enfin des produits sont
fabriqués en france
il aura fallu six mois émaillée
d'incidents techniques pour en arriver
là mais les produits non chauffés ne
sont pas immédiatement retirés de la
circulation
pourtant le 12 mars que dr brunet
informe jacques roux une étude menée sur
des donneurs de sang à l'hôpital cochin
si le donneur sur 1000 sont porteurs du
virus si ces chiffres sont
représentatifs de la situation
parisienne
guy brunet alors il est probable que
tous les produits sanguins préparer à
partir de poules de donneurs parisiens
sont actuellement contaminées
même constatation le 29 mai dans une
réunion interne au cnts tous nos lots
sont contaminés c'est aux autorités de
tutelle de prendre leurs responsabilités
sur ce grave problème mais la tutelle ne
sera pas averti
19 juin laurent fabius annonce le
dépistage obligatoire et la
généralisation des produits chauffés
l'administration doit fixer les délais
de longues semaines vont s'écouler
le directeur d'un centre régional de
transfusion s'inquiètent
fin juin il écrit à georgina dufoix pour
demander au plus vite le dépistage
je sollicite respectueusement une
audience dans la matinée du jeudi 4
juillet dans le délai qui la partie
s'est il n'était pas possible au cabinet
de madame du foie sans que celle-ci
d'ailleurs est eu à connaître de cette
lettre d'accorder un rendez vous dans un
laps de temps aussi court
à part cette lettre il n'y a pas d'
alerte qui arrive directement entre les
mains du ministre au cnts
on sait que les produits contaminés
seront bientôt interdits
début juillet le docteur garetta
rappelle ses consignes pour les malades
elle avait positif lait concentré non
chauffés doivent être utilisés jusqu'à
épuisement des stocks
voilà on sur contamine donc les
hémophiles séropositif c'est ce qui est
arrivé aux deux fils de jean grève l'un
des membres fondateurs de l'association
française des hémophiles
à l'époque il rencontrait souvent michel
garretta non seulement dans les réunions
mais je vois en week-end et l'a nommé
jon campagne à côté de la mienne et 11
mois il vous parle de rien
le 23 juillet deux arrêtés ministériels
sont pris le premier rang obligatoire le
dépistage des dons de sang à compter du
1er août
le second a interdit le remboursement
des produits non chauffés au delà du
premier auteur de quel poids peser
l'année 85 dans le drame de la
transfusion
on estime aujourd'hui que si 90 % des
hémophiles ont été contaminées avant fin
84 ils sont environ une centaine avoir
contracté le virus en 1985 pour les
transfusés dans la période du 20 mars au
31 décembre il y a eu probablement 320
contamination au total près de 350
nouveaux cas dont une bonne partie
aurait sans doute pu être évité
alors pour poursuivre votre explication
en effet zac et on peut dire que sont la
france est en tête puisque pour les
transfusés des chiffres du centre de
surveillance du sida
c'est quatre fois plus en italie cinq
fois de plus en espagne six fois plus je
crois en allemagne et 13 fois plus qu'au
royaume uni
alors pourquoi cette spécificité
dramatique française la france dans
cette comptabilité terrible la france a
fait je dirais malheureusement aussi mal
que nombreux de pays voisins en matière
de démo philly et comme vous le dites de
à nous seuls on représente la moitié des
cas de sida poste transfusionnelle parce
qu'en france on a fait ce que les autres
pays européens n'ont pas fait on a fait
l'énorme bêtise d'aller chercher du sens
en prison laissant le sang en prison
dans un quartier chaud a représenté 1 ou
2 % des apports de sans sarah mais c'est
la cause d'au moins un quart à 40% des
contaminations
il ne fallait pas y aller ça a été dit
ne fallait pas y aller on savait qu'il y
avait un risque est à la fois les
centres de transfusion parce qu'il avait
besoin de sang et l'administration
pénitentiaire pascal acheter la paix
dans les prisons parce que les
prisonniers pouvaient cantine et pouvait
avoir des permissions c'est donner leur
sang et bien les deux réunis ont fait en
sorte que la france connaît cette
exception sur la transfusion qui est un
vrai drame
puisqu'on a comme je voulais tout à
l'heure la moitié des cas européens si
la poste en suivant deuxième réflexion
elle concerne l'est ce que j'appellerai
les maladies contagieuses
on avait peut-être un peu perdu
l'habitude de maladies contagieuses sur
simple qu'on n'a pas réagi et eu
beaucoup de shows vous savez c'est vrai
que ce qui est facile de relire
l'histoire de 85 avec nos yeux
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai qu'à cette
époque qui a eu de la part de la
communauté médicale en particulier puis
c'est le but est aussi de la société une
sorte de
de coma dont on est sorti très lentement
depuis des années 60 il y avait des
vaccins il y avait des règles d'hygiène
qui faisait que la plupart des maladies
infectieuses a disparu soudain arrive
une maladie qui qui ce qui a l'air
d'être infectieuses car de se
transmettre par le sang mais aussi par
par le sperme on comprend pas très bien
dans une période aussi de libération des
moeurs d'une vie différente et cette
maladie elle ennuie tout le monde
mais comme au début est cantonné au
milieu homosexuel on pense que c'est un
phénomène marginal le temps de se
réveiller de comprendre qu'on est face à
un virus comme les autres virus et que
ce virus a en plus une particularité
c'est que quand l'organisme leur
encontre
il ne cicatrisent pas contre lui le
temps de comprendre ça mais il y aura
des centaines de morts alors troisième
aspect c'est l'as fait virer du principe
de précaution
j'irai que ça au moins ça encourager
tout le monde à réagir d'une certaine
manière mais à réagir peut-être
excessivement est une bonne chose ça
permis ce drame aura permis de remettre
à plat le système transfusionnel
français qu'on croyait être le meilleur
du monde on s'est aperçu que ce n'est
pas vrai et dieu merci aujourd'hui je
crois que les choses ont beaucoup mieux
le côté négatif c'est aussi celui gunet
souligné c'est d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui
par peur à chaud de se retrouver devant
les juges que ce soit les médecins les
politiques on a tendance aujourd'hui à
tirer à courir dès qu'il se passe
quelque chose un phénomène minimes on
ouvre le parapluie de façon énorme on en
est on veut une société du risque zéro
qui n'existera d'ailleurs jamais et à ça
pose un problème parce que ça peut
mettre à la fois en péril la recherche
certaines avancées techniques et puis
aussi certaines questions de santé
publique
alors à force d'avoir trop peur on
risque sera peut-être paradoxalement de
régresser mais d'un autre côté il faut
bien penser que le drame qu'on a vécu on
pourrait peut-être lent vivre un jour si
on a le malheur de baisser la garde
et ça ce n'est pas ça lançant d'autres
choses ce dernier sera-t-il évoqué dans
le procès le procès des trois ministres
qui se tiendra donc devant une cour de
justice de la république spécialement
créé votée par les parlementaires
voici ce qu'elle sera avec dominique
verdeilhan et rémy poissonnier au
premier plan la place des trois
ministres voici la salle d'audience
telle qu'elle a été aménagée par la cour
de justice de la république pour ce
procès exceptionnel
voici la salle d'audience tel que nous
l'avons reconstitué en 3d pour mieux
vous expliquer le déroulement de cette
première judiciaire en france
nous ne sommes pas dans un palais de
justice mais dans une petite salle du
centre international des conférences
avenue kléber à paris 150 personnes
seulement pourront assister aux débats
principalement des journalistes et des
victimes une salle vidéo permettra donc
au public d'écouter les arguments des
trois ministres laurent fabius georgina
dufoix edmond hervé ne sont pas jugés
par un tribunal ordinaire
la cour de justice est constitué de
trois magistrats et douze parlementaires
six députés et six sénateurs
l'opposition est majoritaire le
président est christian le gunéhec
ancien directeur des affaires
criminelles et des grâces de jean
lecanuet et d'alain peyrefitte anciens
directeurs de cabinet de jacques chaban
delmas à l'assemblée nationale ancien
haut magistrat à la cour de cassation
c'est dans cette salle que les 15 juges
décideront du sort des trois ministres
sur les cintres les robes noires qui
regretteront magistrats et
parlementaires question procès pénal ou
procès politique des incriminations de
droit commun une procédure de droit
commun des recours de droit commun mais
une cour composée majoritairement
d'hommes peu éthique on retrouve là
l'ambiguïté face aux trois ministres aux
trois prévenus le siège du ministère
public de l'accusation
il est tenu par jean françois bourgeot
là un procureur général près la cour de
cassation et roger lucas avocat général
accusations le terme est impropre car
par deux fois
jean-françois burgevin a requis le non
lieu oui à la responsabilité politique
non à la responsabilité pénale
les victimes seront assises dans la
salle présente mais silencieuse devant
la cour de justice elles ne peuvent se
constituer partie civile
elles ne pourront donc pas apporté la
contradiction au prévenu nous aurons un
rôle passif
nous serons un rôle de public mais c'est
tout
alors si tu embêtant c'est parce que il
n'ya pas d'opposition 60 témoins seront
appelés à la barre des conseillers des
ministres des médecins prescripteurs des
spécialistes du sida
certains d'entre eux étant mises en
examen dans un autre volet de la faire
ils ont décidé de ne pas répondre à
cette convocation
c'est le cas par exemple du docteur
michel garretta le premier à avoir été
condamnée dans cette procédure
ainsi après cinq ans d'instruction
quinze ans après les faits la cour de
justice risque de juger trois ministres
sans avoir tous les éléments du dossier
six sénateurs six députés étaient
candidats pour être ainsi les juges des
ministres aux côtés des trois magistrats
et du président christian le gunéhec
nous avons choisi deux d'entre eux un
sénateur démocratie libérale un député
socialiste pour vous permettre
d'apprécier à la fois la préparation de
ces parlementaires et leur état d'esprit
à la veille de la première audience de
la cour de justice
reportage album nicosie et virgile llado
ancien chef d'entreprise aujourd'hui
sénateur démocratie libérale du var
hubert falco à 51 ans magistrat fils de
magistrat député socialiste de l'allier
françois colcombet à 61 ans deux
générations de formation mais dès demain
ils seront assis côte-à-côte volontaires
pour être juré au procès du sang
contaminé
n'ayant aucune formation juridique
particulière hubert falco dit comprendre
ainsi mieux la souffrance des victimes
j'ai été sensibilisée par des papas ou
lemon qui m'ont écrit
qui ont vécu des moments atroces et donc
je crois que lorsqu'on est responsable
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
disais que croyez moi dans mon coeur il
n'y a pas de place pour la politique
politicienne
la justice c'est l'univers de françois
colcombet un des fondateurs du syndicat
de la magistrature
il connaît parfaitement les procédures
puisque c'est lui qui a présidé la
chambre de la cour d'appel lors de
l'indemnisation des victimes contaminées
bienheureux les français qui savent
depuis le début exactement où est la
vérité dans cette affaire donc
collectivement il faut qu'on trouve la
solution
laurent fabius il était le premier
ministre de gauche il aurait pu être
premier ministre d'un gouvernement de
droite les probables problème se serait
posé dans des conditions extrêmement
voisine
ces dernières semaines hubert falco n'a
rien changé à ses activités il admet ne
pas avoir lu l'intégralité des dix mille
pages du dossier
il a fait le vide dans sa tête ait
oublié jusqu'à son appartenance
politique
pour ma part je ne serai pas partisane
et j'assume aurait pleinement le rôle de
deux magistrats au rôle pour lequel j'ai
été élu par mes collègues du sénat
au contraire cette double étiquette
jurés certes mais aussi politique
françois colcombet la revendique comme
une garantie de sérieux dans les
tribunaux de commerce ou dans les
tribunes plaît
les juridictions prud'homales c'est la
même chose on est désignée juge
précisément parce qu'on connaît les gens
et koné connaît le milieu dans lequel on
est bien on fait l'effort de s'abstraire
et ont fait l'effort de rentrer dans la
logique juridique c'est ce qu'on va
essayer de faire cinq élus de gauche 7
de droite siégeront donc dès demain
proches ou adversaires des ministres
poursuivis ils sont d'accord sur un
point cette nouvelle cour de justice mme
sera respectable que si elle statue en
toute indépendance et en toute rigueur
laurent fabius georgina dufoix edmond
hervé ont l'intention de s'exprimer dès
demain dès l'ouverture du procès on en
saura donc un peu plus sur les arguments
de chacun pour ce soir voici des
explications de javie timbert concernant
les responsabilités des trois accusés
l'hôtel matignon
le sommet du pouvoir chef du
gouvernement laurent fabius était le
plus haut responsable de
l'administration par conséquent aussi le
premier garant de la santé publique
or en mai 85 c'est l'accusation la plus
précise le cabinet du premier ministre
aurait freiné la mise en service du test
de dépistage américain abbott au profit
de son équivalent français
mais pour sa défense laurent fabius
rappellera qu'un mois plus tard la
france et à son initiative
l'un des tout premiers pays à instaurer
le dépistage systématique pour les dons
de sang en décembre 92 le parlement
votait sa mise en accusation et son
renvoi devant une cour de justice
lui-même participé au scrutin
un choix qu'il avait expliqué un peu
plus tôt pour qu aucune équivoque ne
puisse demeurer est aussi odieux que
cela puisse être pour un homme dans les
adversaires même reconnaisse l'innocence
je voterai moi même l'acte d'accusation
qui saisira à mon égard
la haute cour
à partir de demain laurent fabius devra
répondre d'homicide involontaire et d'
atteinte involontaire à l'intégrité des
personnes dans la hiérarchie des
ministres elle était en matière de santé
la première responsable le nom chauffage
des produits sanguins
les collectes de sang à risque georgina
dufoix devra répondre à ces deux
accusations ce qui lui est également
reproché de ne pas s'être à l'époque
suffisamment impliqués dans le dossier
lorsqu'elle fut mise en cause georgina
dufoix avaient donné sa conception de la
responsabilité ne sont tout à fait
responsable
en foot les étangs pour autant je me
sens pas coupable
le dossier retient comme pour laurent
fabius l'homicide involontaire elle
atteinte involontaire à l'intégrité des
personnes à son poste il avait le
contact plus direct avec le monde
médical comme georgina dufoix edmond
hervé devra s'expliquer sur le
traitement des produits sanguins dans
cette période s'explique et tout
particulièrement sur ce sang collectées
dans les prisons hautement susceptibles
d'être contaminés et que l'on a pourtant
écoulé avec selon l'accusation
l'aval de ses services as aux
accusations dont je suis l'objet je sais
que finalement je serais un homme seul
sur les sept plaintes que la cour
examinera à partir de demain 5 vise les
trois anciens ministres
deux concernent seulement edmond hervé
oui il y aura donc cette victime
représentée dans l'acte d'accusation la
procédure on l'a dit ne permettra pas a
priori d entendre certains témoignages
ont été reconnus comme accusatoire c'est
celui ainsi de sylvie roui atteints du
sida à cause d'une transfusion ou mois
d'août 85 mais ce n'est pas le cas d'un
homme et me file qui n'a pas voulu
s'exprimer mais voulu s'exprimer quant
dissimulant son identité
reportage tirer curtet et claude barnier
ce devait être un heureux événement mais
dans la mémoire de sylvie ce2 ou 85 est
synonyme de coûts chemin
le jour de son accouchement elle était
d'anémié le sens qu'on lui a transfusé
n'était pas alors contrôlé deux ans plus
tard elle apprend qu'elle est
séropositive c'est le début d'un
enchaînement infernal monfils aloïs on
s'est senti un certain moment de sa vie
responsable de ma contamination donc il
a dû être suivi par un psychologue
sami plein plein de problèmes quoi
pudiquement sylvie n'évoque pas le pire
moment de sa vie en 96 elle dépérit
elle n'a plus de défenses immunitaires
ont l'hospitalise elle perd 30 kg le
stade ultime
et puis miracle la trithérapie la sauve
c'est surtout pas un accident c'est
c'est c'est un crime on m'a empoisonné
on m'a tuer un docker je veux que
justice soit rendue
c'est sûr que je leur en vain je vais
pas dire que je leur en veux pas ils
m'ont quand même tué mais je sais tu pas
de la vengeance et c'est de la colère
sais c'est que je trouve que ben moi en
tant que citoyens font ces jus mal placé
ma confiance et on m'a trahi je trouve
que c'est de la trahison de leur pain
c'est pour ça que le mont bleu
longtemps elle a tenu caché son
affection maintenant elle reçoit la
presse accepte d'en parler ouvertement
car même si elle a repris une vie
presque normale
elle se sent floué le procès qui
s'annonce ne la reconnaîtra pas comme
victime
mais comme simple témoin
plus procès été long à venir peut-être
qu'on se disait il y aura peut-être une
victime les gens se font des cd parce
que c'est vrai que le sida est une et
personne et je sais pas ça c'est ma
petite idée quoi je me dis moi il y aura
témoins et moi il y aura deux parties
civiles mieux ça sera
chez cet homme aussi la colère est
d'abord tout intérieur sa démarche il la
doit à son hémophilie malgré sa
séropositivité il mène une vie presque
normale et préfère rester anonyme
mais lui aussi se sent trahi une double
trahison d'abord parce que dit il les
décideurs n'assume pas ensuite parce que
sa plainte n'a pas été retenu car comme
la plupart des hémophiles
on ne connaît pas avec précision la date
de sa contamination
les hommes politiques voient arriver un
fait nouveau on leur demande des comptes
et ceux qui leur demandent des comptes
sont des français en du monde
donc ils vont avoir à intégrer un
nouveau facteur c'est que dans leurs
actions vous fera désormais qu'ils
réfléchissent aux implications qui
soient responsables de leurs actions de
vente peuple une analyse froide
déterminée tous les plaignants ont une
même volonté pour ce procès ils veulent
qu'on les reconnaisse enfin
comme des victimes dont conclure avec
vous dominique c'est un procès qui est
inédit à plus d'un titre on l'a dit
composition de la cour procédure fait
que les victimes ne pourront pas
s'exprimer on a même parlé de
monstruosité juridique c'est à dire on
va pas de la confusion entre justice
pénale et responsabilités politiques
oui d'où le procès du procès avant de se
pencher sur le dossier d'accusation
lourdes cent mille pages avant d'étudier
les charges qui pèsent sur les ministres
avant d'entendre leurs arguments les
observateurs ont déjà condamné le procès
jeter au pilori la cour de justice de la
république ce sont les politiques qui
ont tiré les premiers oubliant qu'ils
étaient à l'origine en 92 du
déclenchement de la procédure contre les
ministres oubliant aussi qu'ils avaient
voté la réforme constitutionnelle qui a
donné naissance à cette juridiction
d'exception
alors aujourd'hui c'est le piège
législateur ne peut que souligner les
incohérences les limites les
contradictions les vides juridiques de
cette cour est derrière cette polémique
se profile un autre débat ce monstre
judiciaire at-il sa raison d'être
ne confondons pas responsabilités
politiques responsabilités pénales
si les ministres sont relax et on
parlera d'amnesty déguisé
s'ils sont condamnés cela ouvrira la
voie à d'autres mises en accusation
ministériel dans ce concert de critiques
seuls les trois ministres ne font pas
entendre leur voix
contraint et forcé ils attendent d'eux
c'est qu'un juge pas comme les autres un
certificat d'innocence
une réhabilitation alors c'est dehors
c'est sur le trottoir de l'avenue kléber
à paris que les hémophiles et les
transfusés contaminé feront entendre
leurs souffrances et c'est effectivement
tout le problème de ce procès
exceptionnel la justice n'a pas su
organiser le face-à-face nécessaire
entre les ministres et les victimes
procès que nous suivrons bien évidemment
partir de demain merci beaucoup
rappel des deux principales
d'information nous désert nous avons
développé dans cette édition tout
d'abord ça concerne les obsèques les
funérailles mondial du roi hussein
c'était à amman des dizaines de milliers
de jordaniens lui rendu hommage mais
aussi pratiquement tous les chefs d'état
est roi souvent
de ce monde et amis ou ennemis
adversaires ou partenaires de la
politique internationales se sont réunis
pour rendre hommage au roi hussein et
apporter leur soutien au nouveau roi de
jordanie le roi abdallah et puis demain
à paris s'ouvrira un procès historique
le procès se tiendra devant la cour de
justice heures république
un ancien premier ministre laurent
fabius deux anciens ministres gina
dufoix edmond hervé seront les accusés
de ce procès
en quelques secondes la météo de sophie
davant avec un avertissement des
préfectures d'ile-de-france prudence car
il ya des risques de neige important à
23h20 dans d'un monde à l'autre
paul amar aura du courage puis si
s'attaquera au thème de la chasse le
dernier journal ce sera zéro heure 50
avec laurence ostolaza et puis demain 7h
50 dans les 4 vérités française d'abord
recevoir jean noël jeanneney historien
et ancien ministre à 13h vous
retrouverez carole gaessler et rachid
arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci